Young women and girls in my country, if I
flashback, you know—how I grew up is really
tough.
The environment in which you are born, you
know, the parents you have is very important.
That’s why for me I am very keen and really
advocate for education.
Because what saved me is like, you know, my
parents they had little education but they
had something.
I remember—the day of my birth—because
it’s a long story, I remember my father
and mother telling me how my father had to
ride the bicycle and my mother had to put
a lamp so that they can see the path because
at the time I was born in a hospital.
They had to cross a forest, you know, which
had a lion.
That lion had eaten animals so it was a real
danger.
And my mother—you’re a woman and you’re
pregnant and you are seated on a bicycle.
So eventually they made it to hospital and
the first person to come was my aunt, my father’s
sister.
And her mission was to come and see the sex
of the baby.
And when she opened and saw that I was a girl,
she just made an exclamation, and in my language
it’s like [speaking foreign language], meaning
“This is yet another girl.”
So for her that was really a disappointment
and she sent the message to the village that
my mother had given birth to another girl.
So girls are regarded as useless.
It’s the boys who carry the traditions.
It’s the boys who carry the family name.
And being born in that environment and living
through that and like I said, you know, and
you are being called a prostitute even as
you’re playing.
And then I asked my mother, “What does this
word mean?
Because the men and the boys keep calling
me this word, And yet I have my real name.”
That’s when she told me what that meant,
and I made her a promise.
I said “Mommy, I’m going to really work
so hard in life and embarrass these men by
success in life.”
So that was a driving force for me and lucky
for me they allowed the girls to have an education.
We walked long distances, we went to school,
you know, it was five kilometers.
I don’t know how much that is in miles.
And you are teased, because that’s not your
space, where you’re going to school with
the boys.
But, you know, you just go through that.
And then along the way that’s when the Lord’s
Resistance Army also disrupted our lives in
the village, and they were targeting, again,
the girl-child.
They didn’t want married women.
They wanted virgins.
They wanted girls to take for sexual exploitations.
So again with my sisters we had to flee the
village.
I remember running through those bushes and
forests and ending up in an internally-displaced
people’s camp.
So it’s tough, you know, being a girl.
The sexual exploitation, and if I didn’t
have the parents I have because when my father
making that decision from that camp to move
us far away to the city, having lost everything,
he had his girls in his mind.
And to really drum it into us that we are
not useless, we can amount to something, really
motivated me to get an education.
So it’s tough.
I know it can improve because I’ve seen
it improving.
The more you educate your people, the more
you educate a girl, the more she stays longer
in school, the more you educate parents, the
more they’ll be mindful about education,
and so many other things.